I literally had an actor a Diego and Jay  came up to me he's a terrific actor but  he came up to me and he goes look I was  thinking about a different way that my  relationship with the broomhilda  character could end oh really oh okay uh  what do you think well I wrote it down  okay so you can read it at your leisure  and so I read it and it's where he kind  of saves the day  it's like okay  he gives her Freedom papers he sets her  off he doesn't touch her he comes to me  he goes so what did you think of it what  did I think of it oh you're rewrite  where you're the hero or you're actually  what are the villains no that's not okay  no I'm not doing that so the fact that  you wanted Django to be the hero and the  fact that you put his name in the title  are those connected there there's a  random connection